j'appelle les flics
donc quand l'aspirateur est en phase non
c'est que c'est ton année pour passer
l'aspirateur tu vois tu es un mec cool
mais tu ne fais pas ta part des corvées
voilà si vous mettez 4 vampires dans une
même maison il y aura forcément un
moment où ça va partir en cacahuète et
mike hayes est un peu du genre
pinailleur c'était un dandy du xviiie
siècle
regardez il ya une thèse fantôme je
crois à lui a tendance à être un petit
peu pervers bienvenue dans mon espace
torture miel par contre c'est vraiment
le bad boy du groupe on aime bien boire
le sang des vierges parce que parce que
c'est cool problème c'est que depuis une
centaine d'années c'est devenu compliqué
de rentrer dans les boîtes de nuit un ep
non c'est pas du genre à déguiser les
gens souvent une fausse image des
vampires alors qu'en fait on est comme
tout le monde je m'appelle jc je suis un
vampire depuis deux mois je veux tu être
le patron jeu pour vous faire entrer si
vous voulez tu déconnes il est tellement
con [ __ ] j sais pourquoi tu utilises
pas la porte
je sais pas j'aime bien volé fait venir
un chasseur devant jouer l'avenir juge
juste donné notre adresse
personne ne va manger les cameramans à
la limite saluer
ok tu m'attaques à l'entraîneur angolais
tu triches est vrai supermarché on est
des loups garous paris loubards
pour être un bon vampire il faut déjà
est naturellement sexy